welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and today I'm breaking
down the second episode of what if Peter
Quill attacked Earth's Mightiest Heroes
this episode is a lot sadder than you
think it is maybe I was expecting a mean
quill or a happy Hank Pim but there's so
many call outs Easter eggs to pass MCU
events and people so let's just jump
into it because I want to talk about all
the crazy things that happened in this
episode but first we have some Whata if
Inspire merch over at nerd rot. shop we
have echogear Loki gear and Christmas
for January gear because I think it's a
little too late to order it before the
end of Christmas it's a great way to
support the channel but also look frush
as hell while doing it okay let's jump
into this we opened this episode with a
giant ball of light shooting through the
sky directly towards Earth Peggy Carter
demands that the unauthorized ship must
be shut down they can't reach the USS
base the song playing his love affairs
out of control were then taken to the
ground it's 1988 if you couldn't tell by
the people's 80s fashion look at all
those clothes we're in New York we're
outside a jazz club I think that says
Johnny cords and Howards might be a call
out to Howard Stark this licensed play
on the card just reminds us yes we're in
a different Universe where they have
posters in English but they also of
license plates and alien there's a
billboard for Olympia which could be a
tie into eternals whose home on Earth on
the comics was Olympia it looks like it
could also be kingo's original look from
the comics on it since this takes place
in 88 what HSE happened in 88 in the MCU
well during the events of this episode
in our reality Nick Fury's at Shield
carols with the rambos Hanks working
with shield with Bill Foster and Elias
star this is the year star leaves to
work on his own then you know his
daughter becomes ghost in a horrible
accident the cre scientist marll is
currently posing as Wendy Lawson and
joins project Pegasus which we're
currently seen she just dies next year I
have a lot of those morbid facts and I'm
sorry at the way that I announced them
the ship blasts down on a New York
Street smashing into cars it's ego
shipped from the second Guardians movie
the one where he and mantis traveled in
the egg ship stops in front of the New
York City Hall sliding into a crash halt
the NYPD arrives very confused and not
saving the day outst steps our young
Peter Quill backlit by the bright light
of ego ship our starlord is wearing the
same shirt the same get up he wore when
his mother died in the first Guardians
movie The Red Flannel and his River
rafter canoe shirt that later we see his
girlfriend in and crazy to me was it not
crazy to anybody else that she could fit
into a child's t-shirt couldn't be me
behind the police officer watu Blends
into the building standing as a shadow
and begins narrating not just any kid
but Peter Quill yes and it's our baby
boy quill out on a joy ride I don't like
how menacing The Watcher is with telling
Quill's story like he doesn't know he's
trying to get away from his egotistic
father like what I did there egotistic
ego two heads same coin I think that's
the quote baby quill picks up the cop
car and makes them explode in the second
movie when he started getting riled up
with his Newfound Powers he was able to
make the rocks move and whip around him
like a tornado even drawing them to his
body to make Pac-Man we didn't see him
use telekinesis but it's not surprising
he'd know how to do it if he actually
trained with his father we see the same
clip from the first movie of our baby
quill running away from his grandfather
after his mother died but I I also
really like that we're exploring what if
yandu was a bad guy and just gave him to
Ego like it's a horrible idea but it it
it's questions questions that I wanted
answered our baby quill stares out the
window at the solar system and a as
yandu Grinch Smiles in the reflection we
see yandu still with Taser face in this
universe what a pair then he delivers
Peter to Ego who destroys his mom's
Walkman and then turns it into an
electro ball he broke it in the second
movie as well because he's just he's
just a dick then we go over the same
plan of execution story that ego
revealed in the second Guardians movie
about the expansion where he plants his
own little seeds all over the world and
takes it over you know like men always
do Peter's causing Havoc at the Brooklyn
Bridge literally destroying everything
when adult Peter was being imbued with
ego's powers his eyes turned like a blue
a light blue but it didn't illuminate
like it did right here it did illuminate
purple in the first movie when he was
wielding the orb though we're taking to
Project Pegasus Shield Western Division
headquarters Pegasus stands for
potential energy group alternate sources
United States when Howard Stark was
looking for Steve Rogers he discovered
the Tess they began studying it and
created Pegasus and this new found
organization was created to study the
tessar which included Shield NASA and
the US government as I said earlier
Marbell worked here in the 80s as the
project leader under the name Wendy
Lawson but when she died in ' 89 the
project was kind of closed Pegasus
opened up again not too long after but
once Thor took the test rack back to
Asgard they shut it back down it turns
out baby quill has been out destroying
dozens of solar systems consumed by a
wave of radiation we know now that was
ego and baby quill was lighting the fuse
if you will it only takes 24 hours
within his time of being on those
planets to actually destroy it and
that's terrifying we're with Howard
Stark voiced by John Slattery and Peggy
Carter voiced by Haley Atwell both
returning from the roles as the same
characters in the movies and TV shows I
love when they do this Howard mentions
how Tony is a pain in the ass and Peggy
R towards he has Funk it's almost like
Peggy saw Tony's hologram performance at
the Stark Foundation Tony during this
time was 18 years old and in 3 years his
parents are going to die that came out
much worse than I wanted it to but I
just have to remind y'all because it's a
breakdown timeline order what was
happening in our universe but maybe you
know since it's a different Universe he
won't die well maybe they don't die or
at least by Bucky I hope it's not like a
Canon event pegy becomes our Nick Fury
and begins cooking up the best team the
world's ever seen you see a map with the
coordinates of their location the
farthest is Bucky currently in Russia
next is Prince tachaka and wakanda Hank
Pim and Goliath are both I think in San
Francisco and the middle dot might be
for Lawson who's already at Pegasus in
the Mojave Desert Howard Stark says this
you forgetting we're in the middle of a
cold war all that we are the world
garbage doesn't really play outside of
MTV so like remember during the 80s the
Cold War went to like what like ' 89
this is an ongoing war between the US
and the Soviet Union and their allies
after World War II this was especially
not the time in America when they wanted
to work with Russia so hiring Bucky a
literal sleeper agent just wasn't ideal
in Howard's opinion he also references
MTV as the only diverse thing in media
in life right now and that's sad it's
the80s do you know how many black bands
there were we cut to my favorite Ant-Man
Hank Pim I'm I'm joking you know Paul R
is my favorite Ant-Man I don't think
there's a person that will say that Hank
Pim is their favorite Ant-Man played by
Michael Douglas and with his daughter
hope voiced by mine McGrath he's clearly
having a hard time Raising Hope after
Janet disappeared Janet sacrificed
herself to stop a Soviet missile from
hitting the US literally a year ago from
the time they're currently in in 1987 so
it's only been a year since Janet's been
gone hope mentions an Ant-Man in the
WASP house she was only 7 years old when
her mom left and her dad didn't talk to
her for 2 weeks he was grieving but so
was she so their Dynamic is still
growing stretching Ever Changing Hank's
phone rings it's Howard he hangs up in
his face we don't officially actually
know why Hank hates Howard personally
Janet and Hank were working with Shield
when Janet died I could see Hank blaming
Howard for that as he was one of the
main Folks at Shield during the time and
Ant-Man we see a flashback to 89 Howard
and Peggy are working with Pim until
Hank goes off on Howard for attempting
to replicate and steal his Pim Tech
Ant-Man says this in Civil War and Pim
always said you never can trust a stark
so I just think it's a long Battle of
them Starks being Starks and clearly Pim
is occasionally a team player Hank and
hope enter Pegasus and Hank makes it a
point to say he doesn't work here
anymore though we saw him quit in 89 he
must have quit a little bit sooner in
this universe we run into Goliath voiced
by Lawrence Fishburn another actor who
played their character in the MCU
they're on a role in this episode now R
Bill Foster worked with on Project
Goliath we later see him finding and
taking care of Ava star AKA ghost and
Ant-Man on the was Project Goliath was a
study Foster had with Pim on expanding
their body mass with pin particles he
did grow to be 21 ft while Pim could
only get really really small thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video
you can love holiday season and also
admit that it's stressful travel time
with family marking time with new
years's it can be a lot and if you feel
like you could use a little help with it
all try connecting with a licensed
therapist by using better help starting
therapy can be hard the right therapist
for you may not be in your area and some
people struggle with the face-to-face
interaction of therapy with better help
you can have your therapy sessions as a
phone call as a video chat even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for no additional cost
without stressing about insurance who's
in your network or anything like that if
you think that you might benefit from
therapy consider betterhelp click the
link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com neww rockstars clicking
that link helps support this Channel and
also gets you 10% off your first month
of better help so that you can connect
with a therapist and see if it helps you
this suit it's a perfect mix of Goliath
and the comics the bars across the chest
and the colors are similar in both
costumes I also believe that like
project Goliath was around the 80s and I
never realized how many teams Hank Pim
was a part of and just out of irritation
or fighting with his co-workers left
stormed out was like I I I hate this
place then we're in chose to King to
Chaka by atani who played young tachaka
in the first Black Panther movie he's
wearing the same exact outfit during the
flashback scene but the claws around his
neck are gold not silver we don't know
tala's age but I think kilmonger is
slightly older if not around the same
age Kil monger's dad died in ' 92 when
he looked like eight or nine so I don't
think tala was really even thought about
right now or if he was alive he
definitely had a babysitter Peggy
mentions how wakand doesn't normally
join in global Affairs and it's because
no one knows they exist yet they got to
keep it a secret then Howard says this
it's a pleasure your father was a great
Ally to US during the war yes I
understand you even donated some
vibranium to your efforts we made a
shield out of lost it in the Arctic but
other than that to Chaka and no jobu's
father was a zri who in the comics
fought Hydra with Captain America and I
think that's what Howard is alluding to
here this wasn't Captain America black
panther Flags of Our Fathers released in
2010 we also learned how Howard
officially got by brainum in the make
cap shield and it was indeed a gift a
gift from King tachaka yay I I didn't
know so I was very I like this then this
happens hey how' the commi snagging in
invite gachev wanted the target
contained before he reaches Moscow so he
sent the Winter Soldier so Bucky wasn't
going to be on the team it's only during
this conflict the Soviet Union President
Gorbachev wanted to make sure the baby
quill is fully captured before getting
anywhere close to Moscow so they sent
Bucky voiced by Sebastian Stan and we
got another one it's great seeing the
team you know the team put together you
know in a better world than what we see
them in in our existence you know cuz
Bucky will end up being framed for T
chaka's murder in like what 30 years and
you know kill Howard Stark in like three
so it's just nice seeing them at peace
here Peggy and Howard both know Bucky
shoot Howard knows Bucky when he kills
him they just know if that's actually
him that's not the Bucky they once knew
I knew that would be the case for Howard
since he recognized him before he died
but it's nice seeing in this timeline
even though Steve is gone within Shield
they heard Zola got one of their men and
good friends and turned them into a
sleeper agent Wendy Lawson joins us in
the traditional cre star suit I already
explained her whole thing so we don't
need to get back into it again Wendy
calls Hank the Crusty guy which means to
be annoying you know like a crusty old
man baby quill made his way At Con
Island you know is just being a kid Hank
does the most triggering thing and
stages an attack with his flying ants
attacking this child and it's horrifying
he's jumping off the lights breaking
each bulb like this is just trigger
warning horrifying more broken shards
like the intro to what if when baby
quill breaks the fun house mirrors out
of complete anger then Wendy Lawson
mentions this pull back killer if the
cub in that jet blows there won't be a
planet left to save Lawson used the
tesak to study and create her light
speeed engine core in her ship later we
see what happens when you shoot that
engine core you turn into Captain Marvel
here she specifically says Cube which
makes me think she just straight up has
the Tesseract in that ship and girl if
that's true in this universe what are
you doing Goliath says Problem Child
10:00 referring to the movie of the
little redheaded demon child I love that
movie when they try to escape quill uses
his powers to keep the ship down luckily
Thor steps in and knocks him out when he
passes out baby quill says I thought you
were the dude from Van
Halen and he's talking about young David
ler Roth with his fine self so looks
like ego and quill have destroyed uim
and Asgard in this reality along with
other nine Realms and now they're coming
to Earth uim is also the place where the
frost Giants come from they got my poor
baby in the same cell they put Loki in
in the first Avengers movie it's
interesting because even then they put
him in that cage and Thor lectured
everyone on the destruction Loki had
already left behind like this scene
right here it's the same Avenger it's
just a different Avengers movie on his
way to Earth Thor confiscated one of
ego's celestial seedlings which ego
planted in 1980 Missouri behind the
Dairy Queen essentially needs Peter as a
battery a single Celestial himself
wasn't enough but using Peter as a
second that would work so he's the light
for the fuse to pop off if you will but
they can stop it only with another
Celestial being because it's the only be
that can penetrate the cosmic perimeter
for the seedl and the cutest cutest
cutaway I I actually no cuz I am gr has
some cute cutaways this is the second
cutest cutaway hope is singing Surrender
by Corey Hart a good good hit she stolen
her dad's key card and is dancing around
listening to her mom's Walkman this
scene made me want to cry and it kind of
did she has a heart to- heart with Peter
which of course they do they're about
the same age and he misses his mom and
his mom's Walkman and they both share
that feeling of losing their moms and I
love my mom baby quill says this what's
wrong with Missouri Missouri my dad said
you were an alien dude feed me a corn
dog and call me Springsteen because I
was born in the USA why else do you
think I'd fly 10,000 light years to get
here I'm just trying to get home and now
it's obvious he's 18 we're 18 this bad
boy home also he made a born in the USA
Bruce Springstein reference I got to
give him that hope shrinks down the cell
with pin particles which isn't new we've
seen this done so many times even
shrinking their building down and
carrying it like a suitcase because of
the scene we've seen in the trailer we
should have known that this was just
angry parents looking at a kid for
getting in trouble Howard says this yeah
great blame the absentee father I get
that enough from my own son and they
love blaming each other for each other's
problems but Howard is definitely in the
wrong right here Thor tries to leave
immediately which is common for him to
do he's very imp patient in every movie
he's in he's he's just impatient in a
very silly way ego then arrives on Earth
to finish what starlord started and then
King tachaka offers this there is an
ancient wakandan proverb one only wins a
two-front war by getting out of your
enemy's way we don't know much of
wakanda before the meteor we know from
the first movie five tribes settled on
it called the nation wakanda we're
hoping this is what we see in the new
series The Eyes of wakanda I just want
them to kind of get into the before part
and maybe this will go and tie into that
the looks Wendy and Hank and maybe I'm
reading too into this that they are
giving each other it's like he's hella
flirting with her and we know Janet and
him when they were apart they hooked up
with different people maybe he's just
trying to get with Wendy Thor Imus the
power of lightning and jumps at ego it's
all dramatic but doesn't work when ego
uses his powers to build a giant boulder
smashing into Thor midair when ego began
using his powers The Rock start hovering
around him like it did Peter in the
second movie we also see him literally
becoming one with the planet and using
the resources on the planet to his
Advantage he pieces himself into a
bigger rock version of himself when
fighting adult Peter he can speak
through his Rock duplicates as well and
he did that in the second movie when
he's yelling at Peter store spins and
throws his hammer crumbling a ton of
rock people we saw him smash through
monsters like this in Ragnarok the
animation on that sand dust parting like
the Red Seas for mire is incredible
we've never visited Quill's mom's grave
but this scene is very very sweet
especially with Hank just having a hard
time conveying his feelings up until the
point about Janet being gone just a
vulnerable moment while Howard is trying
to make sure Bucky doesn't kill this
child in the name of Soviet Russia
Howard hits a part of Bucky though in
his feels and Bucky pulls out ego is
charging himself up to send tentacles of
his Electro powers we saw him use this
on adult Peter baby quill and Hank jump
onto the back of the flying ant quill
Yanks the scening and his eyes start to
brighten with the powers just holding it
then ego does it all over again he
admits to killing Peter's mom and caring
only about the expansion just like in
the second movie and Peter absorbs the
seedling taking more of ego's powers as
one Celestial that's okay but two that's
better and shoots all that power back at
ego killing him and the mound believing
him with his Celestial Powers presumably
Quil two ego zero in two universes baby
I'm going to ignore what happened last
episode at the Dairy Queen because I
want to keep giving quill two points he
also tells him my mom calls me a
Star-Lord which in the end of the first
Guardians movie the note she left adult
Peter ended with her giving him the
nickname Star-Lord and here comes the
old Grinch Hank Pim to save the day he
has two kids now they Embrace and
immediately Never Surrender by Cory Hart
plays again and everyone is enjoying a
post-win dinner at Hank's house this
house isn't the new blue house that they
have in Quantum mania this is 88 it's a
different colored house then we have the
this little scene this American libation
is surprisingly delicious what do you
call it uh light beer how exotic another
it's a call back to the first movie
where he drank the drink he liked and he
threw it on the ground breaking it Wendy
did have Goose at this time and it looks
like she's offering up to Hope and Peter
Knowing damn well that thing's a monster
I love Goose though and I love that
they're making a cameo and what if the
Winter Soldier has slightly changed into
a slightly normal Bucky it was a change
of his heart which is good to know that
that could change him Goliath calls Thor
Thunder brother and Hank calls him
Goldie which I think Tony has done
before but also Hawkeye does in the
comics then we get the slow team walk up
that the Guardians love doing so much
our ' 80s Avengers are here and a little
too powerful Peggy Carter King tachaka
Wendy Lawson Goose Star-Lord Ant-Man
soon to be wasp soon to be dead Howard
Stark Thor and Goliath such an
incredible team and Howard thought this
Hands Across America shtick only worked
on MTV what an idiot and that's it for
my breakdown on episode two of what if
Peter Quill attacked Earth's Mightiest
Heroes follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at lulor Clemens follow new rock
subscribe to new rockars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching I'll see you
[Music]
later